and so now we move forward the clock
ticks Michael Ross Bosch is the Peter
Gruber professor of Neuroscience at
Brandeis University an investigator at
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute he's
a geneticist molecular biologist and a
chrono biologist he received his
doctoral degree in 1970 at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Cambridge under Sheldon Penman
subsequently he spent three years on a
postdoctoral fellowship in genetics at
the University of Edinburgh since 1974
he's been on the faculty at Brandeis
University at Waltham where he's
collaborated as you heard with Jeffery
Hall and investigated the genetic
influences on circadian rhythms of the
internal biological clock Michael Ross
Bosch is a member of the US National
Academy of Sciences in more recent years
he has been working on the brain
neuronal aspects of circadian rhythms I
would like to ask you all to join me in
welcoming professor Ross Bosch to the
stage where he will deliver his 2017
Nobel Prize lecture entitled the
circadian clock transcript a
transcriptional feedback and the
regulation of gene expression welcome
[Applause]
so it's a great pleasure to be here a
great honor I this this whole business
since the 2nd of October at five ten in
the morning Boston time has left me
virtually speechless but being
speechless is not really appropriate
here is it so I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to screw up my courage and try and say
something so let me begin by trying to
give you a little introduction to
circadian rhythms and first as I like to
do to not forget this I want to thank my
current lab for the work they're
currently doing which I'll try and
allude to at the end if I have a moment
pay attention to the time here and
especially que tu brute see who's been
with me for 16 years and has made the
trip here to Stockholm to celebrate with
all of us and so circadian rhythms is a
biochemical as as the slide says
physiological and behavioral adaptation
to the rotation of the earth and there
are two purposes to this one is
anticipation namely the early bird gets
the worm and the early worm avoids being
eaten by the bird and secondly the clock
manages to to create internal coherence
so the different reactions different
steps in metabolism for example happen
in order and not all simultaneously
oxidative and reduction reactions are
happiest when they're separated in time
and so circadian rhythms arose a long
time ago in response of course to this
rotation of the earth and the rotation
of the
earth was occurring well before
nutrition anything was anything like
what's currently available on our planet
and well before the atmosphere had its
current gaseous constitution and in fact
the oldest clock we know the clock in
cyanobacteria really participated in
oxygenation of the atmosphere so 2
billion years ago we lived in a we lived
the planet experienced a reducing
atmosphere and it was really
cyanobacteria with the aid of its clock
that produced the oxygen that enabled
life as we currently know it to arise
and so clocks exist really in different
kingdoms not only in bacteria as I just
alluded to but also in plants and in
animals which I will focus on and it's
likely that these clocks arose
independently because there's very
little evidence of a relationship
especially between the cyanobacterial
clock and animal clocks and probably
even the plant clocks arose
independently so this is such a powerful
such a powerful contribution to fitness
that it arose in these independent lines
and so a simple systems view of
circadian clocks a so-called Skinner
Graham named after Arnold Eskin one of
the early pioneers in the field is
illustrated here and and it simply
demonstrates the fact that there are
input signals principally light also
temperature which entrain the clock the
clock does not run exactly at 24 hours
our endogenous period in humans for
example is about 12 to 15 minutes long
and it's light every day which resets
our clock back to 24 hours
those are the input signals and then
there are outputs all kinds of things
that we measure we commonly measure so
called the hands of the clock which of
course are not the clock itself the
clock of the gears inside and the hands
simply respond at various points to the
to the clock itself and and it's really
the the nature of the pacemaker the
nature of the timekeeper which is the
focus of this lecture in fact the focus
of this prize and as as as Jeff alluded
to at the beginning of this problem
certainly the beginning for us not the
beginning of all circadian work but the
modern beginning is really due to
Konopka and Benzer shown here on the
bottom right not at the beginning when
ron was a student in his lab but much
later in an interview and and these two
people and it was really Konopka who
brought the circadian problem to Seymour
Konopka was interested as an
undergraduate in circadian rhythms and
he suggested as Jeff indicated why don't
we apply this genetic expertise to this
biological problem in drosophila and
they isolated three alleles of this gene
they named period and and those three
alleles either eliminated rhythms
altogether they gave there was a short
period variant and a long period
variance the so called for zero allele
per s for short and parelle for long
and remarkably these alleles these
variants had exactly the same effect on
two completely different rhythmic
phenomena namely emergence of the adult
from the pupil case shown on your left
or local motor activity rhythms the
running around of the fruit fly the
fruit flies activity rest cycle now we
know they're sleep-wake cycle which were
which were either absent short or long
exactly
as as one might have anticipated from
the from the occlusion from the
occlusion rhythms so this was a
magnificent contribution and for those
of you who chase high-profile papers and
perhaps this is a different angle on
chefs ed Lewis story in the first decade
after this paper was published it had 10
citations so so you you you the the the
high profile papers are not necessarily
the ones which have staying power and so
in it at Brandeis Jeff and my lab got
together and independently Mike Young's
lab at Rockefeller to clone this gene in
the early days of recombinant DNA and
this is a picture of the group that that
did this wills airing Tony James the guy
in the middle
Jeff Hall for Nita ready that's me
believe it or not and and Dave wheeler
and so it was that group and and in fact
an additional group of people in my lab
who I'm gonna focus on there were also
people in Jeff's lab but I want to sort
of make sure that I acknowledge the
people in my lab who contributed to this
pronita already mentioned Chang you shin
Lo and yo f City who unfortunately
passed away and and that group really
contributed to cloning and sequencing
the period gene in my lab in the early
mid mid 80s and the outcome was that
this was a pioneer protein that meant
this was such early days that the
sequence identified no relatives in the
database seek the number of sequence
proteins was so small that the chance of
hitting upon a relative
a gene with a similar sequence which
might give you a clue as to what the
protein was doing just didn't exist and
so we spent several years struggling to
try to ex mmm find the promised land
from the desert and and one clue for us
was a paper that Changyu produced in
1987 that that suggested that an
intriguing repeat region within the
protein which turns out to be not very
interesting anymore was not necessary
for circadian function in other words we
could take the DNA that encoded the
period protein transform it into an
arrhythmic animal and we got perfectly
good circadian function which was
missing this particular region so that
suggested that we needed to look in in a
different direction and as science often
has it it turned out that the literature
started to provide a bit of a clue for a
direction to look at and this paper was
produced
shortly after Chang's paper from Steve
Cruz and Corey Goodman and they cloned a
Drosophila gene called single-minded and
it was a nuclear protein they actually
didn't know at the time it was a
transcription factor just a nuclear
protein and and it had homology to the
period protein in fact we were now no
longer the Pioneer single-minded was the
new protein and they they were they
benefited from having us there although
of course since we didn't know what our
protein did it was it was a limited
utility except providing a high profile
connection for their paper and so
nonetheless the nuclear localization of
single-minded suggested to us that gene
expression in some way might be relevant
to the function of the period protein
and shortly thereafter Paul Hardin who
was a postdoc in my lab really produced
what is arguably
the most important paper from my lab
that the period gene product the protein
was involved in a feedback loop which
affected which regulated the
oscillations of its own mRNA and and
this is a quantitation of those data and
and the key thing there are key features
of this one is that the messenger RNA
profile goes like this
in time and there are 24 hours between
Peaks but if that experiment is done in
a per short background in which the
period protein has a one amino acid
difference from the wild-type protein
then the distance between those Peaks is
19 or 20 hours rather than 24 hours
exactly mimicking the behavior and so we
proposed that that this must be really
important perhaps central to timekeeping
but as I'll try and explain in just a
couple of minutes it was still a little
bit of work to come up with a more a
tighter more more restricted model and
this is a present that Paul gave me less
than a month ago at a party we had and
this is the original gel showing
oscillations and and and the original
paper under glass refer see you know it
was it was a present that was framed and
so so I cherish this gift thank you Paul
and and this was really not easy to do
for two reasons one is when you use
whole flies there were no oscillations
that were visible you had to use heads
that was his brainchild because in the
body there is lots of tissues which
don't undergo oscillation and that
damped the signal so it really wasn't
visible it's often in science a very
small change which makes all the
difference and and and secondly this is
before PCR so these these assays were
done by RNA protection and that itself
is a little bit of a story which I'll
come to
so this particular gel gave rise to a
model and and I call it a cautious model
this is the actual picture from the
paper the last figure of the paper and
and what I want you to appreciate was
that there was no mention of
transcription in the title or the
abstract in other words feedback loop it
was there was feedback loop but no
mention of transcription and the way we
imagined this was that it could work at
the post transcriptional level for
example maybe messenger RNA half-life
was affected was regulated and not
transcription it could be transcription
and moreover it could be indirect in
other words the period protein could
affect these things directly but perhaps
the period protein affects another
protein which is actually the direct
regulator or or most indirect if you
will is that the period protein could
influence behavior which could in fact
feed back and affect the molecular
oscillations in other words behavior
would actually be upstream as opposed to
downstream of the molecular oscillations
so we were very conservative about this
and and it turned out that over the next
two or three years that there were three
paid for papers that my lab produced the
first of which was really also Paul's
work which cemented the feedback loop
model and emphasized transcription so
this first paper in PNAS and and an
interesting and interesting aside as we
really had trouble publishing this paper
because everyone assumed this was
transcription and I my lab worked on
post transcriptional regulation in yeast
half of my lab and so I was well aware
that this was not a slam-dunk this was
not for sure to be transcriptional and
and what this paper showed was the fact
that the pre messenger RNA the intron
containing RNA also underwent circadian
oscillation
essentially indistinguishably from the
messenger RNA and also you could take
the upstream region the promoter region
of the gene and you could put it in
front of a reporter gene in this case
choline acetyltransferases cat and and
and and that regulatory dammit that
regulatory DNA would would would
oscillate that that that reporter RNA
would oscillate in exactly the same way
as the purr RNA so all you needed was
the upstream DNA really indicating that
this was very likely to be transcription
so the models strongly favored
transcription and then over the next
couple of years
three more papers really cemented this
model one hour only collaboration with
the aforementioned Seymour Benzer
in which immuno electron microscopy was
done to show that the period protein was
really nuclear if we constitutively
overexpress the protein this work done
by Han Zhang Han cui Zhang who was an
eminent neuroscientist today the
scientific director of the Allen
Institute then then this would clamp
period mRNA levels very low and and non
oscillating consistent with a repressor
function and and lastly the the region
of homology between single minded and
period and then a third protein then
so-called named the past domain turned
out to be a dimerization domain which
could account for the how period would
work as a repressor namely by
associating with a positive
transcription factor which contained a
past domain in this this study was led
by josh wong who is and that also an
eminent neuroscientist at Cold Spring
Harbor today so that really led us to
the negative feedback loop model at the
level of transcription and I should say
at this time or shortly before this time
I won a bet from Mike Young I did
for the four of us their wives that gene
expression would be the focus of the
function of the protein and he paid his
debts and we had a lovely dinner and so
he mammals entered the story at this
time when sho Takahashi and his
colleagues initiated and carried out a
really heroic genetic screen in mice in
some ways encompassing the original
Konopka and Benzer work plus the cloning
the seek and the rat and the rescuing
and the sequencing of the protein and
came up with a mutant which affected
circadian rhythms very dramatically
fortunately for them the 25th Mouse
which was several standard deviations
off the norm for the period that they
would normally see here's the wild-type
phenotype and here's the that particular
mutant Mouse and and of course they
named they named that Mouse they named
that gene clock and it turned out to be
a past containing transcription factor
which plays a role in this story and at
the same time in my lab Ravi alotta
who's here and jean rutila were involved
in a lengthy genetic screen to try to
find other circadian mutants and we we
knew about the remarkable work in the
young lab and we didn't want to
duplicate what they were doing looking
for period altered mutations so we
actually looked at a rhythmic mutations
and and it turns out that a rhythmic
mutations are very easy to find we had
more than 40 of them but they're very
hard to sort out to distinguish
interesting ones from uninteresting ones
and so we devised the sub screen and the
sub screen for these mutants was to look
at which of the strains
non-cycling in very low period and
timeless levels the idea being that if
we had hit upon the positive
transcription factor we were looking for
the X in in our diagram then then there
should be no cycling and and low levels
and in fact we only found three three
mutant strains which met that criterion
and two of those turned out to be
alleles of cycle or B mal the ortholog
and mammals and one of them turned out
to be an allele of clock so in fact we
we had closed the circle if you like and
and managed to identify the positive
transcription factor the heterodimer
that drives period and timeless which
then represses clock and cycle and it
turns out three of the same four
proteins function in the same way in the
same way in in mammals and so this is
really conserved in the five hundred
fifty million years or so of evolution
since flies and mammals diverged clearly
present in the common ancestor that
lived long ago and of course i'm
focusing on transcriptional regulation
but there's a whole world of post
transcriptional regulation that mike
mike will allude to for example the
function of timeless and double time
genes that were isolated in his lab so
this is now a common theme as you've
already heard among circadian
oscillators Neurospora plants mice where
an activator leas gives rise to the
synthesis of a repressor which then
increases in concentration and then that
repressor feeds back in the nucleus
interacts with the activator turns off
synthesis of the repressor the proteins
the messenger RNAs and proteins decay
away and the whole system starts again
then so I just mentioned very
briefly something contemporary just to
show that this particular aspect of
investigation is not over this is a chip
seek profile for the active scientists
who might be interested in the audience
this is a sixth time time nighttime
course from the morning and then
throughout the day to the evening and
this is the association of timeless or a
period with the upstream region of the
DNA with these so-called a boxes this is
when the repressors associate and the
black arrows indicate the time at which
clock or the positive factor associates
with these same regions and of course
not surprisingly there's a delay between
the association of the activator and the
subsequent association of the repressors
so the repressors build up and then
associate the turnoff transcription and
it turns out to be to be quite
interesting that the profile if one does
exactly the same kind of assay but in
this case actually tries to identify the
proteins by mass spectrometry that are
associated with the clock site complex
on chromatin that there's a much more
discreet Association of period and
timeless at the time of maximum
repression in other words the by chip
seek the proteins associate continuously
whereas by mass spec there's a much more
discrete feature of association and so
there's something that's very different
that happens at a very particular time
on chromatin that's associated with this
repression step and this is only to say
a word about this particular kind of a
particular kind of assay and so beyond
the feedback loop I just will say a word
about the fact that we and others we and
others have have tried to address the
notion of how much oscillation is there
really and in a paper that we published
in 2000
we made two findings one is that there
are a large number of cycling rnase in
fly heads much beyond this very
constrained small feedback loop and
secondly that none of this oscillation
none of these cycling RNAs happen
without a functional clock psych complex
so in other words the small feedback
loop really does sit at the top of a
hierarchy which gives rise to a large
number of oscillating transcripts and of
course the current view the way to put
this together and create a cartoon to
rationalize this if you like is the fact
that this small feedback loop here which
governs timing there are a few more as a
small or perhaps not so small number of
direct target genes those direct target
genes include other transcription
factors and those other transcription
factors lead to the the oscillation of
secondary secondary target genes and and
output functions and it's really this
this idea coupled with the fact that
there are in in mammals flies as well
there really are clocks in all tissues
of the body not only the brain but liver
kidney the adrenal gland pancreas skin
lung heart etc and and it's really the
the fact that clocks are present
everywhere I think uh leisha blur gets
the lion's share of the credit for
really pointing out doing a seminal
experiment to indicate that this is the
case and the combination of the large
number of cyclers indirectly produced
from the feedback loop plus the many
tissues in which this occurs is the fact
gives rise to the fact that in the
entire mammalian organism more than 50%
of all gene expression is under
circadian control so in other words
in excess of half of the 25,000 genes
that we manufacture are governed by the
circadian clock and it's of course
because of that feature that this
picture makes really some sense the fact
that all kinds of phenomena that were
interested in including sleep which
you'll hear about from Mike Young and
metabolism and all sorts of other things
are really under under the control of
the circadian clock so I'm gonna just
say as it was president in the
introduction that my current interests
are really the the 75 neurons which
function in the fly brain and within
which these red neurons within which the
same circadian feedback loop occurs in
sync and and the question that we're
quite focused on is how do those neurons
give rise to this very complicated
behavioral profile that's characteristic
of Drosophila and many other insects
namely a morning peak of activity a
siesta in the middle of the day as Jeff
indicated these fruit flies are very
smart the the peak of activity in the
evening and that and then sleep at night
and all that whole profile is really
controlled by those 75 neurons and and
I've also become a pseudo neuro
scientists and so we're quite interested
in how to assay firing patterns of
discrete neurons in in wake in weight
behaving flies so flies that are running
around and doing all kinds of behavior
how can you really say the firing
patterns of flies under those non
constrained conditions and firing
patterns of very discrete subsets of
neurons so I think I think I will turn
in the last couple of minutes to a
couple of a couple of philosophical
points and try to
dress this question why am i receiving
this this awesome prize and what did
what did I actually contribute so that's
as Jeff as Jeff told you about its the
AI it's really do the work and a P I who
is ever so slightly introspective asks
himself this question from time to time
and especially at times like this so I
am persistent that's for sure that is a
characteristic of mind
I worked for many years on yeast post
transcriptional regulation and and that
yeast lab of course I didn't have two
labs
I had one lab with two themes and the
people were all intermingled and so
knowing about nucleic acids really
helped our work both experimentally as I
alluded to from the this this rnase
protection experiment of Paul hardens
and also my training the fact is that
circadian rhythms had been dominated by
neuroscience and neuroscientists are
interested at things that happen at the
millisecond level or even sub
millisecond but this didn't make any
sense for phenomena which operates on a
24-hour time scale but the half-lives of
RNA protein proteins does make sense and
and it was with that knowledge that some
of some of this work was done and and
then of course I was smart enough to to
stay out of the way of talented people
and and and let them make progress so
there's a lot of luck in good fortune
that goes into it goes into work that
goes into life my attache this week if
you can believe it is named per so so
III when he introduced himself I said
this I lead a charmed life this could
not possibly really happen to me
that is the nickname of the gene of
course that we worked on so more more
more substantively so I came to Brandeis
AA and I and I encountered genetics I
was not a geneticist before I came to
Brandeis and Jeff was one feature but
only one of several people at Brandeis
who were interested in genetics
recombinant DNA came around just at the
right time for our career this was a
perfect storm I think those of you who
like movies and Jeff Jeff introduced
this this metaphor I could say that
recombinant DNA was our ingrid bergman
and to quote from casablanca of all the
gin joints and all the time towns in all
the world she walked into ours and and
you might not know but the Epstein
brothers who wrote the the screenplay
for Casablanca had two different endings
and on one of them Rick Blaine gets in
the plane to Lisbon along with Ingrid
Bergman and so we had the we're in
Stockholm we we had the happy ending to
this story and and so I also that the
feedback loop was correct in general
that was not for sure
tons of cycling rnase much most of
animal physiology is under control who
knew who knew that's how it would come
out I we were I was fortunate to be
funded by remarkable farsighted
organizations HHMI and I NIH my
university is is is a wonderful
meritocracy those those funding agencies
and meritocracies in my environment was
great I have already mentioned the fact
that we it's really the AIS who do stuff
and of course I had this long friendship
and collaboration with Jeff Hall this
allowed us to put our two labs together
as he mentioned people in his lab like
rafasa Nevsky John you were
I got to associate with co-mentor if you
will in the case of John Patrick Emery
in my lab who's not here collaborated
with Ralph on the cloning of
cryptochrome so and then of course this
this had an element a strong element of
personal friendship we we had we have
strong personality differences Jeff and
I I should say and but we embrace those
differences we I think it was it was
really an asset to our work and
certainly enriched me personally Ralph
Greenspan likes likes to say that we
made him think of Gilbert and Sullivan
who are arguably the most productive
collaborating duo in music and
absolutely drove each other completely
crazy in the course of their
collaboration so here's a list of the
people I worked with and I want to
particularly mention Ravi
Isaac Patrick Josh Wong Shin pronita
these are the early day people Jon
radula
way ching chang chong cui and larry
zwibell they're they're the people who
contributed to the early days of this
story I had a yeast lab as I mentioned
and and those people have gone on many
of them to fame and fortune and they
were critical to my success one of those
yeast people became my wife not job of
it and and of course there's Naja and I
with our two daughters and so as as some
friends of mine like to say not only
would I not be standing here without
them but I would be dead and and and and
lastly let me just say and with family
and Naja is a segue that the science my
view of science is a very romantic
profession you you don't know what
you're going to discover every day is an
adventure and and it's it's really a
great privilege joy a romance as ice
and I think I'll end on that note with a
short poem which is present in Ralph
Greenspan's book fly pushing and it's
written by his wife Danny and here's the
poem Oh Gino type of phenotype this kiss
had better last her he's off to see his
other love Drosophila melanogaster thank
you very much
[Applause]